Morning. Hey kiddo.
I love you.
It 's my first time on a commuter train. What about you?
Every day, past ten years.
Ten years? You must know everyone on this train.
-I 'm sorry. Have we met?
-No, I'm Joanna.
-Michael.
-I study human behaviour.
My job
is you to answer one basic question.
What 's that?
What kind of person are you?
As an experiment. What if
I asked you to do something as could profound  the  affects
an individual on this train
-I don't understand
someone on this train does not belong
all you have to do is find them
In the bathroom, there is 25000 dollars
the money is yours
if you do this one little thing
I thought it was hypothetical
What kind of person are you?
I'm not gonna do this
try to set me up.
-No one forced you to take that money
What do you want from me?
This is one little thing.